but but I think what is important
brother Eddie is that you keep doing the
good work what you are doing I think
that the Dean show which is watch on
different satellite television and all
that it needs support of the community
Muslim need to realize that you know you
teach one person one-on-one you're
teaching one person when you're teaching
on television you are teaching hundreds
and thousands of people if not Muslim
need to master the art and technology of
communication we need to be stronger and
that's the way America wants after nine
eleven a lady called me she picked up
sound vision brochure in some Mehsud and
she called me and he said would you I am
NOT a Muslim would you mind talking to
me I say of course by all means you said
you know a would channel should i look
for Islam I want to learn about Islam so
would channel I go to I remain silent
and say we don't have a channel you know
what did she say she remains silent said
then how do you know how do you think
Islam America will know about Islam
Howard America will know if you are not
on TV yeah so thank you for being on TV
hamdullah and let's do more of the same
and I asked the audience right here
looking at you my brothers and sisters
if you feel your hurt if you feel you're
being wrong if you think zoom is being
done by Muslims or people of other
faiths you need to speak stand up you
need to speak up but one of the things
which you can do people who are standing
up people who are speaking up with the
television program and radio and what
not support them that's our message need
to be gorgeous remember prophets allah
allah allah salam use each and every
means of communication to connect
whatever was available at the time goo
it in the market going to the Kaaba
going Farage inviting pilfer party hey
if prophets allah allah allah salam is
alive today don't you think he will be
on TV how you can convey how you can
talk to billions of people unless you're
on TV so support they didn't show
and speak up and keep smiling thank you
so much